[Music]
here in a tranquil and secluded rural
setting Benjamin Horne wells mission is
to establish a training center in a
former monastery here in trizol t an
academy with extremely conservative
outlooks with his so-called Institute
for human dignity horn well has set
himself an ambitious goal to save
Western civilization mobilizing
Christians and Jews in the fight against
Islam he refers to religious role models
for his mission the picture here behind
me is his martyrdom Saint barthélemy was
skinned alive for his faith in Jesus
Christ and we've got to remember that
today in the world Christianity is the
world's most persecuted religion we
often forget that in the West the
Academy aims to train budding young
politicians to become staunch Catholics
and right-wing populist s' resulting in
the next generation is going to become
the global headquarters of the fight to
defend the judeo-christian basis of
Western civilization so that's just not
just here in Europe but right across the
world
the Catholics seemed to look on Steve
Bannon as the ideal partner for the
project Donald Trump's former chief
strategist regularly meets with Hartwell
in Rome they first met when Bannon ran
the ultra-conservative Breitbart news
website
fanon is enthusiastic about horn wells
project
I'm just honored he's asked me to help
out and you know what I'm trying to do
is add maybe a little organizational
ability in and in bringing donors
faculty people I would know throughout
the world they can teach Bannon wants to
bring together populist and identitarian
forces in Italy and other European
countries
a patronage by conservative Catholics
suits his cause very well he also has
his eye on next month's European
Parliament elections because the
populist nationalist sovereignty
movement has great politicians a great
message and now it has traction and
that's why it's on the cusp maybe if the
momentum piece through Spain and other
nations a stunning victory in May for
Bannon the Academy should become an
ideal breeding ground for his Crusaders
among its backers are ultra conservative
circles within the Vatican who reject
Pope Francis's liberal calls for
inclusion and support of immigrants
[Music]
the American Cardinal Raymond Leo Burke
is head of the Board of Advisors of the
Institute and result II he has openly
endorsed Donald Trump's conservative
agenda in the United States critics see
the emergence as an unholy alliance that
will seek to use to result II to
undermine democratic societies led by
arch conservative Catholics who rely on
the help of political agitators like
Steve Bannon what they have in common is
this obsessive cult of identity they say
we represent Christendom Western
civilization Europe founded on
judeo-christian values and we are being
invaded so we must defend ourselves
many local residents int result II have
launched protests they don't want Steve
Bannon and far-right populist here the
monastery is a religious site both a
place of pilgrimage and a tourist
attraction they want the government to
rescind the lease on the property where
is the local monastery being used for an
ideological project trees Ooty will
become the launch pad for a movement
look at its ideas its sources of finance
and its goals if you'll read up a bit
cause up Benjamin Horne well remains
confident the lease is valid he says the
plans to start operations are in place
so what can stop him in Benin now
culture is upstream of politics and
that's where we're working at certain
anything that we're going to do would
help matter salvini and any of the
property fastest populist nationalist
movements in in in europe around the
world Horn wells plans seem clear result
II should become a launching pad for
far-right populist s-- to take over
Europe one that can count on the
blessing of arch-conservative
Catholic clerics in high places
[Music]
the Academy aims to start its first
courses this summer but before that it
remains to be seen how well the
Nationalists and populist spur form in
the European elections in May